ouvry nos frontières fini la pandémie
redonner mois le droit de voir ma
famille des messages scandée par une
vingtaine de résidants de la région du
madawaska dans le nord-ouest du
nouveau-brunswick
puis on voit pas pourquoi on veut fait
hôtel l état d'urgence parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'urgence
premièrement j'ai de la famille qui
demeure au québec j'ai une soeur et un
frère que d'autres peuvent pas venir du
tout ma soeur elle est venue une fois
elle a été mis en état d'arrestation ils
y ont donné une fin le nouveau-brunswick
interdit depuis le 25 mars le passage à
tous les voyageurs non essentiels à
l'exception des personnes qui ont de la
famille dans la province elles doivent
cependant s'isoler 14 jours à leur
arrivée le petit groupe rejoint une
quarantaine de résidents de la région du
témiscouata à la frontière du québec est
délimité par un ruban rouge
je reste encore ici à notre dame du lac
mon regret c'est d'avoir la commune
n'est pas plus élevé qu'un et quel
niveau brunswickois mom a refusé d'aller
aux funérailles de mon père mais vous où
est-ce qu'ils auraient juste dix
personnes mais les manifestants
demandent le droit de passage à l'image
de la nouvelle bulle atlantique qui
permet la libre circulation des
résidents des quatre provinces depuis
vendredi et où le québec madame je sais
tout risqué mais juste à côté et je sais
compter du mob the corny complètement
bizarre a fait que je comprends pas ce
qui se passe le pourquoi la journée si
tu passes ton temps français c'est parce
que on est des virus angulaire une idée
qui fait son chemin dans une motion
c'était de regarder à cette nouvelle
zone d'exception est appuyé en partie
par la préfète de la mrc du témiscouata
qui demande elle aussi des
assouplissements à la frontière mais
pour les familles uniquement
c'est pour permettre quand même urgent
d'avoir une vie un peu plus normale
parce que si c'est pour se prolonger
encore des mois
je pense qu'il ya vraiment de la grille
très certaine la frustration gronde des
mesures d'urgence implanté par le
nouveau-brunswick pour limiter la
propagation de la cofidis neuf semble de
moins en moins populaire
la province pourrait bientôt changer son
fusil d épaule avec une ouverture des
frontières au reste du canada qui
pourrait entrer en vigueur à la fin du
mois ici nicolas steinbach radio canada
à moncton